- Thanks to Indochino for
keeping Legal Eagle in the air
and helping me look fly.
(eagle crying)
The Senate impeachment trial
of President Donald Trump has begun,
and day one was filled with fireworks,
bombshells, lies, and deception,
things that bode well and
terribly for your case
whether you are a
Republican or a Democrat.
There was something for everyone.
So, let's dig in to all of the craziness
that happened on day one.
Let's also find out why Senator Ted Cruz
apparently is singling
me out for trolling.
(dramatic music)
Hey, Legal Eagles, it's
time to think like a lawyer,
because the first day of the
impeachment trial in the Senate
was filled with all kinds of lawyer skills
and complete sophistry.
So, let's dig in to some of
the more important things
that happened during the first day,
because a lot has changed,
and it's going to set the tone
for the rest of the impeachment trial.
The first day of the
trial was ostensibly about
setting the rules for
the rest of the trial,
and indeed, they did, in fact,
set some ground rules for
the rest of the trial.
Interestingly, in the
run-up to this first day
of the Senate trial,
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
had said that he was going
to pattern the proposed rules
off of what was used in
the impeachment trial,
the idea being that if it was good
for the trial of a Democratic president,
it would be good for the trial
of a Republican president as well.
The proposed rules had been held back,
and it was only over the
weekend that we got to see
what the proposed rules
were going to look like.
And interestingly,
McConnell had made several key
changes to what was proposed
compared to what was used
during the Clinton impeachment trial.
For instance, two of the
major key changes included
that all of the argument
would have to be compressed
into a 24-hour period
spread out over two days,
and that the evidence that came
from the impeachment hearings in the House
would not be admitted automatically
into the Senate trial.
Those were big deviations
compared to the Clinton-era rules.
But interestingly, it
seems that those changes
were repealed at the last
minute after a meeting
with some of the more
moderate Senate Republicans.
So now, the rules that were approved
on a strict party line vote
require that the argument be
made over a three-day period,
which is commensurate with what happened
in the Clinton trial,
but also that evidence from
the impeachment hearings
in the House can be admitted
into evidence in the Senate.
However, with one big
caveat that is a deviation
from the Clinton trial,
that the evidence is subject
to objections from the White
House or other senators,
including hearsay,
which is problematic, to say the least.
Now, of course, the Senate can
make whatever rules it wants.
It can adopt the Federal
Rules of Evidence or not.
But what we've seen is
that there are plenty
of misunderstandings about
what hearsay actually means,
and we've covered some of
those misunderstandings
on this channel.
It's going to be problematic because here,
a lot of the testimony that is relevant
to the president's motivations
and the president's actions
are necessarily going to include things
that other people have said.
Those things, for example,
what the president told Rudy
Giuliani or Mick Mulvaney.
Those things are relevant
in and of themselves
as legal acts,
which would defeat an
argument that they're hearsay.
But even things that Rudy
Giuliani told other people,
including potentially Lev Parnas
and other associates of
Giuliani and the president,
would potentially be considered hearsay,
but they would be admissible in court
if it were an actual court
because they are
declarations against interest
or declarations of a party.
There's all kinds of
reasons why even, quote,
hearsay evidence would come in.
So, the carve-out is
particularly interesting
from a legal perspective,
but it is ripe for abuse,
because people simply don't understand,
sometimes willfully don't understand
the idea and concept of hearsay,
especially in this context.
As I mentioned, it was a
straight party line vote,
53 Republicans, no defections,
to 47 Democrats, no defections.
Now, not only did the
Senate procedural rules
cover the amount of time given
to both sides to make their
case and their defenses
and the admission of
evidence that was procured
during the House impeachment proceedings,
but it also covered the new
evidence that will be added
to the Senate trial.
Or more specifically,
it did not cover the evidence
that will be added to trial.
For all intents and purposes,
the Senate is kicking that
question down the road,
though that's not necessarily
the end of this story.
The senators can always
pick up this question again
with some of the more moderate Republicans
arguing that they will
make a second decision
once they have heard all of the argument
from the House managers
and the president's defense attorneys.
And that does comport with what happened
in the Clinton trial
where that decision was not made up front,
but was made several weeks
into the Senate trial.
Though, it's also
possible that the senators
will not take up this question again
and there will be no
additional new evidence
in the Senate trial.
Which raises the specter
of what commentator Dahlia Lithwick
summarized the Senate GOP position as,
it's too late for impeachment witnesses
and it's also too early
for impeachment witnesses.
The Senate GOP has been arguing
that the witnesses should have been called
in the impeachment hearings in the House,
and that it's also too early
to address that question in the Senate,
and also by the way,
no witnesses should be allowed in either
the impeachment hearings in the House
or in the Senate impeachment trial either.
And the Republicans argue at the same time
that the Democrats should
wait for the courts
to decide these questions
of the subpoenas themselves,
and whether the witnesses
can be compelled to testify.
At the same time, arguing that the courts
have absolutely no right
to decide these questions
because of separation of powers issues.
It does often feel like the arguments
are that it's never the right time
and it's never the right forum
to decide these questions.
Again, in strict party line votes,
the Senate Republicans voted to dismiss
11 amendments that Senate
minority leader Chuck Schumer
tried to add to the Senate rules,
each of which attempted to bring in
various kinds of evidence
into the Senate trial,
including subpoenas for documents
and witnesses from the White House.
These amendments would
have approved subpoenas
for things like communications
between the White House and
Ukrainian President Zelensky,
documents and testimony from individuals
like acting Chief of Staff Mick Mulvaney,
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo,
and former National Security
Advisor John Bolton.
And in a really interesting gambit,
one of the amendments would have allowed
Chief Justice Roberts to make the call
as to which subpoenas for
testimony and documents
would be approved.
But again, along strict party line votes,
the Republicans voted not to allow
any new evidence to come in
and voted down an amendment
that would've vested the power to decide
whether new evidence would come in
with the chief justice
presiding over this trial.
The next set of fireworks
came from the Democrats,
who came out swinging and
arguing substantive points
on the first day of the trial.
Now, by all accounts,
it was thought that
everyone was simply going
to discuss the procedure
and procedural rules
that were going to govern
the rest of the Senate trial.
The Democrats used their time
in their opening statements
to talk about the substantive
arguments for impeachment.
Whether you like this tactic
or you found it to be
complete histrionics,
this is an interesting
and classic trial tactic,
to use all of the time that you have
allotted in front of the trier
of fact or the trier of law
to get your point across.
This is something that happens
in lawsuits and trials all the time.
I've seen it many times
where lawyers argue with a judge,
digging straight into their arguments
when the judge doesn't
really have any idea
of what they're talking about.
Whereas if you give some background
and argue a lot of your
substantive points up front,
then the more nuanced points
that you might make later on
will actually resonate with the judge,
who has a million things on their docket.
And the tactics that Adam Schiff
and some of the other Democrats took
on the first day of the Senate trial
sort of hearkened back to
that particular trial tactic,
that instead of simply arguing
the mere procedural points,
which they eventually did,
especially with Chuck Schumer,
they took that opportunity
to start making their case
in front of the Senators
and the American people.
So, whether you liked that tactic or not,
whether you thought it
was pure grandstanding,
or you thought the Democrats
were making some good substantive points,
it has its basis in classic
litigation and trial tactics
to be able to get your story out
at every avenue that you can,
and not just be cabined into
the specific issue in front,
but to be able to talk
about all of the issues
at the same time.
Because of course, if you have a theme,
you want to reiterate that
theme or that narrative
as many times as you can,
hoping that it will stick.
And of course, it was interesting
to compare the Democratic narrative,
which went into the substantive issues,
with the narrative put out by
the lawyers for the president,
who it appears were prepared to argue
for the substantive points,
but perhaps not all of the
substantive arguments on day one.
Which leads me to the next
part of this impeachment trial
that really struck a chord
with me as a practicing lawyer,
was the marathon nature of
this particular proceeding.
This may be a feature, not a bug.
When you're in trial, the
judge sets the schedule,
and there's a reason why often,
trial starts at 10:00 a.m.
and wraps up by 4:00 p.m.
with maybe two or three
hours of substantive things
actually happening during the day.
The reason is that the jury
will get fatigued over time.
It's really, really hard
to be glued to your seat
for a full business day,
listening to all of these really complex
and arcane arguments.
And of course, the same thing is in effect
with the Senate trial as well.
This day one of the trial
went long into the night,
and unless you are a legal freak like me,
you probably had better
things to do during the day
than to watch 12 hours of
testimony and argument on C-SPAN.
That has an effect.
It's very clear that both sides
are going to get fatigued,
that the American people
and that cramming so much into one day,
it's gonna be hard to follow
all of the different
things that are happening,
and things are gonna get chopped up
into soundbites by both sides.
It's gonna be really hard to pay attention
as the weeks go by and this continues.
Now, one thing I thought
was particularly interesting
is that both sides, both
Republicans and Democrats,
are arguing that these
impeachment proceedings
both in the House and the Senate
are precedent-shattering
and are hugely different
from everything that has come before.
And in some respects, they're
definitely both right,
and one of the reasons for that,
and one of the huge reasons
why the evidentiary issues
are so incredibly important in
these impeachment proceedings
compared to impeachment
proceedings in the past
is that there was no
independent investigation.
By necessity, the House had
to do the investigating,
which it's really not set up to do
and is bound to get locked up
in separation of powers issues.
In the only two other modern
examples of impeachments,
we had an independent counsel
doing the investigating.
In the Nixon era, we had special
prosecutor Leon Jaworski,
who was able to do a
thorough investigation
into the Nixon affair,
including being able to
subpoena documents and testimony
from individuals,
which admittedly went
up to the Supreme Court,
which forced the White House
to turn over the famous Nixon tapes.
That's one of the reasons
the investigation took years to complete.
In the Clinton era,
we had independent counsel Kenneth Starr,
who again, had the full
force of the executive branch
to do an investigation into
the various Clinton affairs.
Often, when you're talking
about impeachment in the House,
the analogy is made to
the criminal context
where the impeachment is an indictment.
There is some investigation,
but often, you are waiting
for additional evidence
to come out through
further investigations,
where the trial in the Senate
is like a criminal trial in real life
where it can use the
evidence that was found
in the House impeachment
indictment, so to speak,
like a grand jury investigation,
but more can come out during
the Senate trial itself.
That analogy is probably a good one,
but in practice, what we have had is,
in the last two impeachment proceedings,
there was a thorough investigation done
before it ever got to
the trial in the Senate.
And of course, when it
comes to the Nixon affair,
it never even got to
the trial in the Senate.
House manager Adam Schiff made this point
on the floor of the Senate
during the first day of the trial
when he said that the
Clinton impeachment trial
was more about recalling witnesses
than it was about calling
witnesses in the first place.
So, regardless of which side of the aisle
you happen to stand,
this is very different,
and it may be different out of necessity
because we don't have
an independent counsel.
One was not appointed by
Attorney General William Barr,
and we don't have the same kinds of laws
that would have appointed
a special prosecutor
like Leon Jaworski to do the investigation
that the House necessarily
had to undertake,
which is very, very new.
Of course, another legal bombshell came
actually from the
defenders of the president,
and may have severe repercussions
for ongoing litigation,
because the president's defenders argued
that the Democrats should have waited
for the courts to decide a lot
of these evidentiary issues
and procured more evidence in the House
before going to the trial in the Senate.
The thing is, there's
active, ongoing litigation
over the subpoena to former
White House counsel Don McGahn.
The White House has argued that the courts
have no business adjudicating
the White House's refusal
to turn over Don McGahn for testimony.
The DOJ as recently as last month
argued that courts can't adjudicate
the privileges used for
separation of powers issues.
The thing is, on the floor of the Senate,
the president' attorney Jay Sekulow
argued that Democrats rushed things
and should have waited for
the judiciary to weigh in.
- The rush to impeachment,
to not wait for a decision from a court
on an issue as important
as executive privilege.
The president's opponents,
in their rush to impeach,
have refused to wait for
complete judicial review.
- Other lawyers for the
president are in court
saying the exact opposite of
what they're telling you today.
They're saying you cannot
enforce congressional subpoenas,
that's nonjusticiable.
- That is such a stunning
admission and contradiction that,
if I was one of the lawyers
working on that particular case,
the Don McGahn case,
I would probably file an emergency motion
with the Court of Appeals saying
that the Trump administration
has basically conceded the issue,
and that the Court of Appeal
needs to compel the
testimony of Don McGahn.
Now, there's sort of a pet theory
going around the Internet
that Chief Justice Roberts
as the presiding judge over this trial
can save a lot of these issues
and can rise up and can prevent
some of the obfuscation
from the Republicans.
I would say that that theory
was dealt a serious blow
during the first day of the trial
when Roberts really didn't do anything
and wasn't even given some of the power
that the Democrats want him to receive,
and that Roberts is really just going
to try to disappear and
fade into the background,
like his predecessor
William Rehnquist did.
Really, the only thing
that Chief Justice Roberts
did on the first day
when he chose to speak
was to dress down both sides and say
that neither is upholding the decorum
that is required for these proceedings.
- I think it is appropriate at this point
for me to admonish both the House managers
and the president's counsel in equal terms
to remember that they are addressing
the world's greatest deliberative body.
One reason it has earned that title
is because its members
avoid speaking in a manner
and using language that is not conducive
to civil discourse.
- But that's sort of par for the course.
That's what you would expect
the Chief Justice to do,
to fade into the background
and let the political bodies
deal with the political questions.
So, I would expect more of the same,
more fading into the background
and both sides-ing all the issues.
Of course, in one of
the biggest surprises,
senator Ted Cruz apparently singled me out
by intentionally misusing the
famous table-pounding quote.
- You know, there's an old saying
that if you have the
facts, you bang the facts.
If you have the law, you bang the law.
If you don't have either,
you bang the table.
- Now, of course, I can't
be certain that Senator Cruz
is singling me out by misusing a quote
that I've used many times
on this particular channel,
but it really does feel like
he's turning it on its head
when the Democrats, whether
you liked it or not,
spent hours upon hours
talking about all the evidence
that the White House is holding back,
the fact that they haven't
produced a single document
or allowed any White
House witnesses to testify
in the House or the Senate.
Whether you liked it or not,
they were talking about
the substantive arguments
and making use of the evidence and law
that is relevant to this particular case.
And of course, the craziest thing of all
is that while this is
all going on in the US,
President Trump is in Davos
where he gave a press conference
where he specifically bragged
about how he is not giving
the Democrats any evidence
and that he's holding it all back.
- We're doing very well.
I got to watch enough.
I thought our team did a very good job,
but honestly, we have all the material.
They don't have the material.
- Now, if I was trying
to be charitable, here,
I would say that President
Trump is just saying
that all of the evidence is in his favor.
But he specifically
uses the word material,
referring to the actual
physical things themselves
and not their metaphorical significance.
- We have all the material.
They don't have the material.
- So, it really does
seem like the president
is bragging about obstructing Congress
and preventing them from getting
any of the relevant evidence,
and not the fact that he's just bragging
about how the evidence supports himself.
It really is sort of
hilarious that the president
always seems to say the
quiet part out loud,
and by hilarious,
I mean that in the saddest way possible.
So, the Democratic argument
often boils down to saying
that the president is a liar, liar,
and his pants are on fire.
And if his pants really are on fire,
then he should really buy some new ones.
So, Mr. President,
if you're looking for
a custom slim-cut suit
that is shockingly affordable,
I can't recommend Indochino highly enough.
All of my suits are now made by Indochino,
including this brown checked three-piece,
and if this suit looks familiar,
it's because I unapologetically
stole the design from Blake Scott.
Blake, just know that imitation
is the highest form of flattery.
There's just one thing I
wanted to change, though.
I wanted to change the lapel
from a notch to a peak,
and with Indochino, not only
could I choose the fabric
so it was exactly the same,
but I could tweak it so
that it was 100% my own
and 100% custom,
which is exactly what I did.
See, the secret to a great
suit is all about the fit.
I'm a reasonably athletic guy,
and I can never buy suits off the rack
because they just simply never fit right.
If the shoulders fit,
the waist is too small.
It either doesn't fit or it costs a ton
to have a tailor fix it after the fact.
But with Indochino,
you can send in your measurements online
or you can go to one of their stores
and have a stylist take your
own specific measurements.
I made an appointment, I
went to a store in person,
and had a stylist work
with me for over 90 minutes
to make sure that my
fit was exactly right.
My personal stylist took my measurements,
and a couple weeks later,
I got the best-fitting
suit of my entire life.
It was perfect right out of the box.
Indochino will make
you a fully custom suit
tailored specifically for
you for less than $400,
and the best part is,
they still use the best materials,
like Super 140s wool and cashmere.
In fact, Legal Eagles can get
any premium Indochino suit
for only $359.
That's $359 for a custom suit
that you design yourself.
All you have to do is use
the link in the description
or use the promo code
LegalEagle at checkout.
Using the link in the description
really helps out this channel.
I will never buy an
off-the-rack suit again,
and once you try it, neither will you.
Just click on the link in the description.
So, do you agree with my analysis?
Do you think we'll see new
evidence in the Senate trial?
Leave your objections in the comments,
and check out this playlist over here
for all of my other Real Law Reviews
where I talk about
impeachment-related things,
copyright, all of the
legal issues in the news,
where I will see you in court.